it shortly before sunrise in the Namib
Desert but these men are ready to break
camp their Rangers with the save the
Rhino trust the men want to set off as
early as possible because temperatures
will soon climbed to over 40 degrees
Celsius the group will be spending three
weeks in the wilderness far from
villages in one of namibia's most
forbidding terrains the best way to
Patrol is on donkeys the tracking teams
are monitoring the last of Africa's
black rhinos living in the wild and
protecting them from poachers about 150
of the animals roam the pristine desert
landscape Omega theta we often spend
days on end in the heat looking for
rhinoceros other animals like lions
leopards and elephants pose a danger to
us but we have to find out as much as we
can about the Rhinos their numbers their
state of health and their behavior last
whistles that's a prerequisite for
protecting them the first success of the
day the men have discovered Rhino tracks
the local Rangers learn to track animals
when they were children some of them
used to be poachers themselves driven to
it by poverty now as gamekeepers they
earn a regular wage na ma SI phan don
nirankari giggle i used to poach because
we were hungry it was about getting me
not trading in rhino horns but I really
prefer feeding my family by protecting
the animals mrs. on mom's in
they continue on foot for several
kilometers always following the trail of
the rhinoceros off in the distance
mountain zebras they've adapted to the
harsh habitat in the Namib Desert
suddenly money chicken awesome spies
what they've been tracking for hours
after a fleeting moment the black rhino
trots away
the Rangers follow it because they need
photos in order to identify it precisely
but the Rhino has caught wind of them
and suddenly charges the team
black rhinos are more aggressive than
other members of their species but this
time the Rangers get off lightly also
can you quickly we were a little too
close but we do have to register and
record all the animals specific physical
features thanks to that information we
now have the most extensive rhinoceros
data bank in the world tourists from
around the globe come to northwestern
Namibia to observe the last of the wild
rhinos this desert camp combines
business sense with nature protection
because the Safari operators support the
work of the conservationists some of the
Rangers are pain from the profits and
other locals benefit as well dick Aleppo
Shabbat ela nuh tengo q okay Tasha we
paid the local population of fee for the
right to use the area for tourism we
also create jobs for guides waiters and
other personnel tourism is basically the
only economic prospect for the people
here yangon o la batalla depot abbott
ave amo Sheeran
rino tracking is subject to strict rules
the Rangers supervise and guide the
tourists to make sure that the animals
are undisturbed today's group is
especially lucky
they get the chance to quietly observe a
rhinoceros cow and her calves it's a
rare sight and evidence that the rhino
population is growing again but we see
it in their way the same the rhinoceros
team members explained that now some
animals have actually been resettled
from the project area to other parts of
the country the tourists from
neighboring South Africa are impressed
in their country rhinoceros poaching is
it an all-time high the way its gang at
the moment it's it's a Daniel slide from
what I can gather as well as we almost
at their watershed now where the the
growth rate has become negative the rate
of poaching has outstripped the rate of
births in rhino so it's a major problem
animal protection advocates in Namibia
are also alarmed only recently a black
Renault was killed in the middle of the
project area with 16 gunshots the
poachers then sawed off its horn since
then the organization has increased its
patrol flights showing a presence as
part of the deterrence strategy
fears are growing but after South Africa
rhino poaching syndicates will target
Namibia
the Syndicates they're very powerful
they've got a lot of financial backing
and they also using people inside the
country's inside so every girl and other
African countries to do the dirty work
for them they are really powerful the
illegal trade that wildlife is more
profitable at the moment the next
try the drugs illegal
junction zone tourism is an important
component in the struggle against
poaching thanks to the regular income
most locals have understood that they're
rare wild animals are more valuable
alive than dead defending that success
against the rhino syndicates will be the
Namibian animal protectionists greatest
challenge in the future